so in the middle of the entire
California gubernatorial recall which we
covered yesterday and already earlier
today on the show an insane bombshell
story dropped on the basis of a
forthcoming book from journalist Bob
Woodward and Robert Costa where there
are a number of disturbing and dystopian
claims and stories that are made and
told
and we have to start with what maybe the
craziest one which is that General Mark
milley was so afraid that in the
aftermath of losing to Joe Biden Donald
Trump would launch nuclear weapons that
Millie had to assure China Trump's not
completely out of control and Millie
even having an emergency meeting with
other top military brass to try to
figure out a way of if Trump tried to do
this can we actually stop him from doing
it and we'll talk about whether this
would even really be possible okay so
let's
um start with a CNN article a reporting
on the contents of the book listen to
this two days after the January 6 attack
on the capitol
Trump's top military advisor Joint
Chiefs chairman General mark milley
single-handedly took secret action to
limit Trump from potentially ordering a
dangerous military strike or launching
nukes according to Peril a new book by
legendary journalist Bob Woodward and
Veteran Washington Post reporter Robert
Costa Woodward and Costa write that
Millie deeply shaken by The Assault of
January 6 was certain that Trump had
gone into a serious mental decline in
the aftermath of the election with Trump
now all but manic screaming at officials
and constructing his own alternate
reality about endless election
conspiracies if five percent of this is
accurate Trump was completely losing his
mind behind the scenes exactly as we
believed he was doing Millie worried
that Trump could go Rogue the authors
right you never know what a president's
trigger point is Millie told a serious
serious senior staff
in response Millie took an extraordinary
action and called a secret meeting in
his Pentagon office on January 8 to
review the process for military action
including launching nuclear weapons
speaking to senior military officials in
charge of the National military command
center the pentagon's War Room Millie
instructed them not to take orders from
anyone unless he was involved now is
this even does this break chain of
command we're going to talk about that
in a second
no matter what you were told you do the
procedure you do the process and I'm
part of the procedure Millie told the
officers according to the book he then
went around the room looked each officer
in the eye and asked them to verbally
confirm they understood got it mili
asked according to the book yes sir
Millie considered it an oath the
author's right
Peril is based on more than 200
interviews with first-hand participants
and Witnesses and paints a chilling
picture of Trump's final days in office
the book Woodward's third on the Trump
presidency recounts behind the scene
moments of Trump's unhinged and
explosive actions yelling at senior
advisors and AIDS as he desperately
sought to cling to power it includes
reporting of the events leading up to
the January 6 Riot Trump's reaction and
newly revealed details about Trump's
January 5 Oval Office Showdown with Mike
Pence Woodward and Costa obtained
documents calendars Diaries emails
meeting notes transcripts and other
records
um
one other part of this and then we'll
we'll get into some some discussion
millisphere was based on his own
observations of Trump's erratic Behavior
his concern was magnified by the events
of January 6 and the extraordinary risk
the situation posed to U.S national
security Milly had already had two back
Channel phone calls with China's top
General who was on high alert over the
chaos in the U.S the then Millie
received a blunt phone call from Nancy
Pelosi Woodward and Costa obtained a
transcript of the call during which
Millie tried to reassure Pelosi the
nukes were safe Pelosi pushed pushed
back what I'm saying to you is that if
they couldn't even stop him from an
assault on the capitol who even knows
what else he may do and is there anybody
in charge at the White House who was
doing anything but kissing his fat butt
over all of this Pelosi continued you
know he's crazy he's been crazy for a
long time according to Woodward and
Costa Milly responded Madam speaker I
agree with you on everything
and then what maybe is the key uh
Revelation here
is Millie becoming so afraid of Trump's
actions Millie ended up back channeling
with uh Chinese officials and saying
it's gonna be okay we've got this under
control so we are quite literally
talking here about a president going
nuclear an actual lunatic as president
and it's the same people who thought
that this Trump was the guy that it made
sense to make president who now don't
want the vaccines so think about that
for a second now there's a real question
here and a bunch of people emailed me
about this saying is Millie in a sense
overstepping Authority here uh later
we're going to get to clips of trump
calling what Millie did treason I think
that that's outrageous but did Millie
overstep Authority here I think the the
most sort of balanced and sober reaction
to this is that ultimately Millie would
not have authority over Trump when it
comes to nukes and preventing him from
launching them okay at the end of the
day whatever system Millie puts in place
uh as a chairman of the Joint Chiefs
Trump could fire Millie
and then replace him with someone who
ultimately will allow Trump to launch
nukes now what I think Millie was trying
to do here
is given the limited amount of time that
Trump would have to do this remember the
riots were on January 6th Milly's
meeting was on January 8th Trump was
leaving office on January 20th or 21st I
don't remember inauguration day at this
point so you're talking about under two
weeks
my belief is Millie knows that
ultimately
uh Trump can fire him and put some yes
person in who will let Trump launch
nukes ultimately Trump can get his
launch order through but Millie knowing
Trump probably realizes Trump has this
sort of uh limited attention span and
eventually if it's too difficult to get
it done Trump will look the other way or
his attention will go to some other
shiny object so obviously at the end of
the day it comes down to you know the
nuclear Silo officers to actually launch
missiles it is ultimately at the
discretion of the president but my
understanding is Millie's idea here was
let's just make it difficult enough so
that Trump would have to fire me and
maybe other people in order to get this
done and maybe that prevents it from
happening the real story here is the
mere fact that the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs was so afraid this would happen
is an incredible historic story that
goes to the unhinged and erratic nature
of Donald Trump a little bit later on in
the show we're going to get to some of
the reaction from Trump to the story
coming out
when we're talking about sleep we always
hear about how much sleep people get but
often neglected in the conversation is
the quality of that sleep which is just
as important and science shows that
lowering your body temperature during
sleep can help you be more rested and
Achieve better sleep and that's where
our sponsor chili sleep comes in chili
sleep makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
help you improve your sleep comes in two
varieties the uler Sleep System and the
cube Sleep System that's what I have on
my bed both are hydropowered temperature
controlled luxury mattress pads you can
make your bed as cold as 55 degrees I
choose 60. you can make it as hot as 115
degrees if that's your thing I don't
feel hot anymore at night no more
sweating I'm sleeping better and I love
it I also have the chili sleep chili
blanket which helps keep me cool on top
as well they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to
chiliesleep.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video